vous connaissez jean claude dusse c'est
un personnage culte de la série de film
les bronzés
célibataire il passe ses vacances dans
des clubs plus pour faire des rencontres
que pour se reposer seulement il est
très maladroit il dit souvent je vais
conclure
et puis en plus je sens que ce soir je
vais conclure mais il ne conclut jamais
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'il n'a pas
compris que la conclusion ça se passe
après la séduction
[Musique]
qu'est ce que ça veut dire conclure le
verbe conclure vient du latin conclude
ehret qui signifie fermé conclure ça
veut donc dire mettre fin à un processus
dans un processus de séduction ça veut
dire obtenir ce qu'on attend de l'autre
personne
le problème de jean claude dusse vous
l'avez compris c'est qu'il veut conclure
avant même d'avoir séduit or ce qu'il
doit réussir à faire c'est séduire et
alors conclure sera facile ça se fera
tout seul c'est la même chose en
dissertation ne fait pas la même erreur
que jean claude dusse n'essayez pas de
séduire
lorsque l'enjeu est de conclure à quoi
sert une conclusion de dissertation
simplement à rappeler les résultats de
la réflexion pas assez à séduire la
séduction du correcteur ça se joue dans
l'introduction et dans une moindre
mesure dans le développement de votre
dissertation et pour séduire le
correcteur vous avez surtout besoin
d'une chose une méthodologie efficace
vous en voulez une inscrivez-vous à mon
cours gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation soit en cliquant qui
s'affiche en haut à droite soit en
utilisant celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo d'un cours
par email donc vous pouvez d'abord
regarder cette vidéo
et puis vous lirai beaucoup après ou
bien dans quelques jours j'en reviens à
la conclusion de la dissertation comme
je voulais dire l'enjeu n'est pas de
séduire le correcteur et donc il ya
d'abord des choses que vous devez éviter
de faire je veux d'abord vous parlez de
ça dans cette vidéo je vais vous donner
ma note to do list de la conclusion je
vous révèle a même ensuite mes deux
formules pour rédiger
bonne conclusion de dissertation ma
formule idéale lorsque vous avez au
moins cinq dix minutes pour écrire la
conclusion puis ma formule express grâce
à laquelle vous pourrez rédiger une
conclusion dans l'urgence en une deux
minutes maximum
regardez attentivement cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout et vous économiserez du
temps et du stress
dès votre prochaine épreuve de
dissertation
[Musique]
pour rédiger facilement la conclusion
d'une dissertation il y a deux choses
que vous ne devez pas faire
la première c'est l'ouverture qu'est-ce
que l'ouverture vous le savez
probablement ce sont là où les toutes
dernières phrases de la conclusion d'une
dissertation
elles sont censées élargir le propos
ouvrir de nouvelles perspectives et les
partisans de l'ouverture n'en disent
jamais plus cette définition suffit pour
comprendre le problème de l'ouverture
voyez ce que je veux dire eh bien on
nage dans le vague
élargir le propos ouvrir de nouvelles
perspectives
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire précisément voici donc
la première raison pour laquelle vous
n'avez pas intérêt à rédiger une
ouverture il n'existe pas de consignes
précises
il y a quatre autres raisons pour
lesquelles il vaut mieux éviter de faire
une ouverture vous risquez de souligner
une idée qui aurait mérité de figurer
dans le développement et du coup vous
mettez en évidence une faille dans votre
argumentation
vous restiez d'évoquer une idée banal
maladroite puisqu'il faut aller encore
plus loin dans la réflexion faire une
ouverture devant d'une maîtrise de la
discipline et une maturité
intellectuelle propres à un prof pas à
un élève
enfin comme vous êtes à la toute fin de
l'épreuve de dissertation vous manquait
probablement de temps en fait s'embêter
à faire une ouverture ça n'est pas du
tout rentable
c'est un détail dont vous vous préoccupe
ray au détriment de l'essentiel
regardez plutôt les quelques minutes que
vous y consacrerez y est pour vous
relire avec plus de soin vous trouverez
probablement des fautes d'orthographe
qui ferait mauvaise impression sur le
correcteur pour vous convaincre
je vais vous montrer un exemple tiré
d'un site qui conseille lui de faire une
ouverture à la fin de la conclusion
lisons l'ouverture pour bien londres
compte du problème ainsi il est possible
de s'interroger sur la responsabilité
des terroristes quant à leurs actes les
frères tard naïve sont considérés comme
étant responsables des attentats qu'ils
ont commis le 15 avril 2013 lors du
marathon de boston
toutefois on peut se demander s'ils
étaient libres et conscients de leur
action ou non
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne idée de terminer une dissertation
philosophique sur la liberté en invitant
à réfléchir à la responsabilité des
terroristes je ne critique pas la
pertinence de l'idée qui est exprimée
mais le choix de cette idée le
terrorisme est un sujet complexe et
sensible qui divise la société en parler
en ouverture c'est prendre le risque de
dire une bêtise et de heurter la
sensibilité du correcteur en
l'occurrence on pouvait trouver les
idées moins risqués à la place mais le
plus simple est de ne pas à faire
d'ouverture voilà j'espère que l'exemple
vous a convaincu seconde chose à ne pas
faire dans la conclusion d'une
dissertation mobiliser une connaissance
je voulais déjà dit dans mon accroche la
conclusion sert à mettre fin au
processus de séduction et non pas à
séduire
j'ai eu tellement de copies qui se
termine par un vers de poésie par une
citation ou bahreïn références
originales
les élèves qui font ça crois qu'ils vont
impressionner le correcteur à la toute
fin de la dissertation
mais généralement l'introduction et le
développement ont déjà déçu le
correcteur en fait c'est la même chose
que dans les interactions sociales
ce n'est pas une phrase une punchline
que vous lancer à la fin de
l'interaction qui va vous sauver est
persuadé l'autre personne de vous
accorder ce que vous attendez d'elle non
c'est surtout ce que vous faites est ce
que vous dites au début et puis tout au
long de l'interaction ne tombait donc
pas dans le fantasme et ne vous prenez
pas la tête à essayer d'impressionner le
correcteur à la toute fin de la
dissertation
souvenez-vous donc pas d'ouverture ni de
connaissances dans une conclusion de
dissertation voilà je vous ai expliqué
ce qu'il ne faut pas faire maintenant et
je vais vous dire ce qu'il faut faire
non
j'ai d'abord vous dire ce que vous devez
faire dans des circonstances normales de
rédaction c'est à dire si vous avez le
temps d'écrire une bonne conclusion
c'est d'après moi la formule idéale pour
une conclusion de dissertation sur
quelle idée repose ma formule
l'idée c'est que pour rappeler les
résultats de votre réflexion vous devais
résumer votre cheminement intellectuel
c'est un peu comme lorsque vous donnez
les directions à une personne qui vous
demande le chemin dans la rue vous allez
à droite puis tout droit et quand vous
apercevrez telle chose tel immeuble ou
tel magasin là vous tournerez à gauche
et c est bien vous devez faire la même
chose dans la conclusion d'une
dissertation
mais dans le monde et des idées
maintenant vous avez compris le principe
de ma formule je vous dévoile la formule
elle même c'est très simple vous
commencé par rappeler le point de départ
de votre réflexion et ensuite vous allez
faire la même chose pour chaque grande
partie pour appeler l'idée générale de
la partie en une phrase puis vous
synthétiser les arguments de cette même
partie en une phrase par exemple si vous
avez rédiger une dissertation en trois
grandes parties de trois paragraphes
c'est à dire trois grandes parties de
trois arguments chacune et bien si vous
avez rédigé une telle dissertation alors
votre conclusion aura la structure
suivante rappelle du point de départ de
la réflexion
rappel de l'idée du grand teint synthèse
des arguments du grand un rappel de
l'idée du grand deux synthèses des
arguments du grand deux rappels de
l'idée du grand troyes et enfin synthèse
des arguments du grand troyes si vous
avez bien compté
ça fait cette phrase au total une phrase
pour le point de départ de votre
réflexion puis deux phrases par grande
partie une phrase pour appeler l'idée de
la grande partie et une pour synthétiser
les arguments et manière générale si
votre dissertation comporte n grande
partie vous devrez écrire deuxième plus
un phrase en conclusion je vous rappelle
une phrase pour le point de départ de
votre réflexion puis deux phrases par
exemple partie une phrase pour appeler
l'idée de la grande partie et une pour
synthétiser les arguments je vous montre
un exemple
voici la conclusion de ma dissertation
sur le sujet
deux faits s apprendre à mourir le point
de départ de ma réflexion et surlignés
en jaune
le rappel des idées des grandes parties
sont en rouge
enfin jean de rouge et les synthèses des
arguments sont surlignés en bleu clair
si vous voulez voir plus d'exemples
lisez mon article sur la conclusion de
la dissertation
j'ai mis le lien dans la description de
cette vidéo voilà vous connaissez
maintenant ma formule idéale pour
rédiger la conclusion d'une dissertation
avec cette formule vous écrirez
facilement presque automatiquement des
conclusions ce efficace et consistante
mais comment faire si vous n'avez pas le
temps
[Musique]
assez souvent vous n'avez pas le temps
de rédiger la conclusion de votre
dissertation
vous avez mal gérer votre temps et vous
vous rendez compte qu'il ne vous reste
que quelques minutes pour rédiger la
conclusion bon la première chose que
vous devez savoir c'est ce n'est pas
grave vous n'allez pas rater votre
dissertation parce que vous écrivez la
conclusion à larache donc reprenez vous
l'envoie cette inutile oui vous êtes
dans une situation d'urgence
mais qu'est ce que je vous ai dit au
début de cette vidéo on s'en fout de la
conclusion vous le savez bien ce n'est
pas grâce à la conclusion que vous allez
réussir la dissertation
bon maintenant vous avez compris ça quel
est l'objectif à atteindre
si vous n'avez que quelques minutes pour
rédiger votre conclusion
l'objectif c'est de réussir à écrire
quelques lignes qui rappelle les
résultats de la réflexion le plus
rapidement possible vous devez donner
l'impression au character qu'il ya bien
une conclusion qui fait le job
étonnez vous devez être très rapide vous
ne devez pas avoir à réfléchir
vous ne devez pas chercher vos mots la
solution c'est donc le copier coller
voici donc ma formule express pour
rédiger la conclusion d'une dissertation
vous recopiez la première phrase du
paragraphe de problématisation de votre
introduction c'est à dire la phrase qui
présente le point de départ de votre
réflexion et ensuite vous recopiez
grosso modo votre annonce de plan en
consacrant une phrase à chaque grande
partie c'est à dire que si vous avez
annoncé votre plan en une seule longue
phrase et bien vous mettez des points à
la place des virgules
avec cette formule express la conclusion
d'une dissertation en trois parties fera
quatre phrases une phrase pour le point
de départ de la réflexion est il pour
l'idée de chaque grande partie à une
manière générale si une dissertation
comporte une partie est bien une
conclusion express fera l + 1 phrase
encore une fois une phrase pour le point
de départ dans la flexion et une pour
l'idée de chaque grande partie voici par
exemple ce que ça donnerait pour ma
dissertation sur le sujet philosopher s
apprendre à mourir
la phrase qui présente le point de
départ de la réflexion et surlignés en
jaune puis les idées des trois grandes
parties sont surlignés chacune d'une
couleur différente si vous voulez voir
plus d'exemples lisez mon article sur la
conclusion de la dissertation
j'ai mis le lien dans la description de
la vidéo voilà vous connaissez
maintenant ma formule express pour
rédiger la conclusion d'une dissertation
avec cette formule vous pouvez écrire la
conclusion en moins d'une minute
plus vous avez de temps plus vous avez
intérêt à reformuler le point de départ
de votre réflexion est votre annonce de
plan en revanche si vous devez rendre
votre copie le plus vite possible alors
ne réfléchissez pas copier coller si le
correcteur se rencontrent ce qui est
possible et bien s'il s'en rend compte
il ne vous en tiendra pas rigueur
et puis de toute manière vous l'aurez
déjà séduit avec votre introduction
[Musique]
je voulais déjà dit pour séduire le
correcteur vous avez besoin d'une bonne
méthodo je vous invite donc à vous
inscrire pour recevoir mon cours
gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite soit
en utilisant celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo si vous avez
des questions sur la conclusion de la
dissertation n'hésitez pas à me les
poser dans les commentaires et je vous
répondrai avec plaisir je suis romain je
suis toujours avec mon fidèle aristote
et vous étiez sur mille idées de culture
générale rappelez vous que vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête
elle a vraiment pas vous n'avez vraiment
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
réussir la conclusion de la dissertation
[Musique]
non